optimal at this altitude I can run flat
out for a half mile before my hands
start shaking and I ask you a personal
question now it is soon I'm a cybernetic
organisms living tissue over metal
endoskeleton this episode is brought to
you by Vimeo Pro which is the ideal
video hosting platform for entrepreneurs
and in fact a bunch of my startups
already use vimeo pro including
wealthfront who uses it to explain how
wealthfront works TaskRabbit uses it to
tell their company's story and there are
many other names you would recognize
among their customers Airbnb etsy etc
why do they use it well Vimeo Pro
provides enterprise level video hosting
for a fraction of the usual cost
features include gorgeous high quality
playback with no ads up to 20 gigabytes
of video storage every week unlimited
plays and views and a fully customizable
video player which can include your logo
custom outro etc you also get VIP
support and you get all of this for just
199 per year that's seventeen dollars a
month with no complicated bandwidth
calculations or hidden fees and you can
try it risk-free for 30 days so check it
out vimeo com forward slash business
that's VI m EO calm forward slash
business and use promo code Tim to get
twenty five percent off that's a special
discount just for you guys so check it
out vimeo com forward slash business
promo code Tim this episode is brought
to you by wealth front and this is a
very unique sponsor wealthfront is a
massively disruptive in a good way set
it and forget it investing service led
by technologists from places like Apple
and world-famous investors it has
exploded in popularity in the last two
years and they now have more than two
and a half billion dollars under
management in fact some of my very good
friends investors in Silicon Valley have
millions of their own money in wealth
front so the question is why why is it
so popular why is it unique because you
can get services previously reserved for
the ultra wealthy but only pay pennies
on the dollar for them and this is
because they use smarter software
instead of retail locations bloated
sales teams etc and I'll come back to
that in a second I suggest you check out
wealthfront calm forward slash Tim take
the risk assessment quiz which only
takes two to five minutes and they'll
show you for free exactly the portfolio
they put you in and if you just want to
take their advice
run with it do it yourself you can do
that or as I would you can set it and
forget it and here's why the value of
wealthfront is in the automation of
habits and strategies that investors
should be using on a regular basis but
normally aren't great investing is a
marathon not a sprint and little things
that you may or may not be familiar with
like automatic tax loss harvesting
rebalancing your portfolio across more
than ten asset classes and dividend
reinvestment add up to very large
amounts of money over longer periods of
time wealthfront as I mentioned since
it's using software instead of retail
locations etc can offer all of this at
low costs that were previously
completely impossible right off the bat
you never pay commissions or account
fees for everything they charge Oh point
two five percent per year on assets
above the first fifteen thousand which
is managed for free if you use my link
wealthfront calm forward slash Tim that
is less than five dollars a month to
invest eight thirty thousand dollar
account for instance now normally when I
have a sponsor on this show it's because
I use them and recommend them in this
case it's a little different I don't use
wealthfront yet because I'm not allowed
to here's the deal they wanted to
sponsor this podcast but because of SEC
regulations companies that invest your
money are not allowed to use client
testimonials so I couldn't be a user and
have them on the podcast but I've been
so impressed by wealthfront that I've
invested a significant amount of my own
money at least for me in the team and
the company itself so I am an investor
and hope to soon use it as a client now
back to the recommendation as a Tim
Ferriss show listener you'll get fifteen
thousand dollars managed for free if you
decide to open an account but just start
with seeing the portfolio that they
would suggest for you take two minutes
fill out their questionnaire at
wealthfront calm forward slash Tim it's
fast it's free there's no downside that
I can think of
hello boys and girls lemurs and
squirrels crazy Bulgarian seated across
from me you too you little lemur this
embarrass and welcome to another episode
of the Tim Ferriss show I'm sitting in a
dungeon of hotel room I don't know why
it is so damn dark in here and I feel
like I am going to have my fingernails
pulled out by some type of operative but
before we go down that dark trail I'm
going with this typically what I do on
this show is I deconstruct world-class
performers and tease out the habits and
routines and so on that you can use
their favorite books morning routines
and whatnot this episode is no
difference and instead of a chess
prodigy or someone in the military we
have mark bittman mark bittman at
bittman be itt m.a.n on twitter is the
author of 20 acclaimed books maybe more
including how to cook everything which
is a series Food Matters and his latest
how to bake everything which is on a
coveted shelf in my own kitchen and many
of you may not realize that I started
cooking with baking for the cyclical
ketogenic diet which we talked about in
this episode for more than two decades
that's 20 years people his popular and
compelling stories appeared in The New
York Times where he was ultimately the
lead food writer for the Sunday magazine
and he became the country's first
food-focused op-ed columnist for a major
news publication he's done a lot
starting for TV series including the
Emmy award-winning years of living
dangerously he's been a distinguished
fellow at the University of California
Berkeley a fellow at the union of
concerned scientists and it was real it
was recently appointed to the Faculty of
the Columbia's muleman School of Public
Health I'm not hi folks I'm just in the
war room on book launch that explains it
throughout his career pittman to strive
for the same wall to make food in all of
its aspects understandable and he also
extends that two brand new podcast
called get bit be itt and in this
episode we talk about my fasting regime
why I do it the way I do it but if
ketosis here a bit of ketogenic diet
there we discuss his face
favorite failures what he's learned the
first piece his breakthrough in the
world of writing or journalism and much
more so without further ado as I always
say please enjoy this episode with Mark
Bittman mark welcome to the show great
to be here to him thank you for having
me I really appreciate making the time
and I thought we would just jump into
rather than asking you the 17 questions
that you've been asked most often what i
would call rapid-fire questions now all
that means is I'm going to attempt in my
sometimes long-winded way to ask short
questions your answers your answers
don't have to be sure they can be as
long as you would like the first
question I wanted to ask trying to steer
away from the most trodden path is if
you had to give a TED talk on something
that you are not known for at all
something that is perhaps an obsession
of yours or an interest of yours of
people we're very few people know about
what would you talk about as gonna say
cooking which is obviously totally the
rock that's the only one on the
foreboding list I did sort of this quiet
passion but I happened to have turned it
into a career so we'll let that go you
know I guess running I guess it would be
running because it's I did used to write
a little bit about running and um you
know it's funny i'm in a down sort of a
down moment in my running life but I've
had those before and I know that I
always come back and it's just as I age
it's just an interesting thing to keep
track of and an interesting thing to
note that I not at this point I think
it's 45 years I've been running so I
even if I'm not running i see other
people run it just stimulates my
thinking about it and is there any for
instance I've read a little bit of
haruki murakami in his running certainly
Malcolm Gladwell well-known runner what
is it that you get out of running and
did you start really young I started
when I was in my 20s I started as a way
to stop smoking cigarettes which worked
and I you know I have gotten so much out
of running um you know besides general I
think overall fitness I was a terrible I
was like the slowest kid in my group of
boys when I was growing up I was almost
always the last or second to last one
chosen when we were playing games i was
just a terrible athlete the worst runner
and when i started running as a you know
as a as a hobby and I you know I
realized I was never getting obviously
never going to be among the fastest
people but I had great endurance I
really enjoyed it i could get into this
space ahead place that I really liked
and I just kept running longer and
longer distances I've run a bunch of
marathons and I think I name is this
combination of fitness and self worth
and then the kind of daily when it's
going well the kind of daily high of
just putting your head in a different
place and getting tired and feeling good
about the way your body feels so that's
you know what I listen to those things
that's a lot you can't get that out of a
lot I mean you can get it out of any
daily exercise where it feels like you
make progress I guess but that for me
because i was competitive with myself or
even with where i would be in a given
year I mean I'm never going to break any
of my older personal records but just to
like make progress it's it's just
something very rewarding about it very
reinforcing uh this is going to be a
left turn but these are all going to be
left turn so I guess we'll just end up
going in a weird square over and over
again but I cool what what books besides
your own have you gifted most to other
people um I don't you know I i have
bought uh I was gonna say I buy one off
I see a book someone will like and I'd
buy that I have bought bird by bird by
Annie Lamott through a number of people
who've told me that they were struggling
with writing because I think it's a
really great writing book and it's a
good read and it lasted yeah fantastic
book you know I I used to buy catch-22
for a lot of people because I just
thought if you hadn't ready you had to
but maybe that year is over and you know
I is there anything else i bought
cookbooks by other people that I've
bought Marcella Hazan books for people
and Julie sahni books for people because
those are the best i think basic italian
and indian books respectively maybe i
don't buy a lot of I like I said I think
it's mostly one off so I'll see
something I think someone i know will
like and just send it so as if we're
looking at one offs and continuing in
that thread what purchase and doesn't
have to be exact but what purchase have
say less than a hundred dollars but
something not terribly expensive it
comes to mind that has had a significant
positive impact on your life could be
anything the iphone headset I don't know
an electric shaver okay those are all
fair answers you're you're singing like
questions those are all fair a kilo tin
of anchovies I mean I like you know I
think I could probably go on because
those are yeah it's funny to talk about
purchases because I feel like in the
past year in the substance talking about
books I was thinking about Amazon but I
dropped amazon prime because i felt like
i was buying things too easily I felt
like I wasn't thinking about you know
it's not even really the cost because
most stuff is inexpensive or negligible
but you know it's not like I was buying
washing machines on you know if I needed
if I needed a box of tissues I might buy
a case of tissues that kind of thing and
I just thought I just thought it wasn't
thinking things through enough thinking
through purchases enough and then I
started to realize how much
stuff I had and how easy it would be
just as easy to give things away or to
go shopping in my closet for clothing or
that kind of thing so I like a in the
last year or so I've become less of a
consumer more thoughtful about this and
more thoughtful about how things decline
in value some things decline in value
tremendously the minute you buy them we
think about cars but if you think about
clothing it's sort of the same thing and
I try to focus purchases on stuff that i
need and and stuff the tire quality and
that goes especially for food but
because you do need to use food up so
you do need to buy that more and more
but um but it's interesting that I
basically six months ago or so I said
I'm going on a three-year clothing
strike just not going to buy anything
and that hasn't exactly been true but
compared to what I was like before I'm
you know it's like if I need something I
needed to rain Jack if we're backpacking
trip I was going on I bought it but i'm
not buying things on whims i'm not
buying things because they quote unquote
nice it's more like you have enough
sweatshirt it probably have sweatshirts
for the rest of my life you mentioned
did you say gallant in aventurine
vangeli kilo kilo am i right yeah you
know you can buy salted anchovies
anchovies coming you know two ways they
come or that is preserved anchovies they
come salted or they come packed in oil
and if they're salted do then rinse them
off and you can pack them in oil
yourself or not but it's they keep they
keep really well you can use a couple at
a time it's a little less expensive
they're pretty high quality general they
come from Sicily or elsewhere and
southern Italy so I don't know if that
was just an example I do like that and
it's a nice can everybody buys the same
this is one producer that everyone's the
name of the producer I don't know it's
Sicilian stuff
so there's no masking is that I actually
travel with cans of sardines and I was
turned on yes by a scientist named
Dominic dagostino so are you just eating
them as as a solo did often as a snack
yeah but what tell me about that because
I'm curious well well Dominic d'agastino
he researches a number of things but he
focuses on metabolism and is more
recently focused on exogenously tone so
these are ketone esters that mimic the
physiological state of fasting at in
some respects and your brain utilizes
ketones very well so he's looked at how
ketones in the dietary state of ketosis
along the lines of say in Atkins diet or
if it's induced by fasting can affect
everything from cancer growth even with
very aggressive cancer growth like
glioblastoma and things along those
lines he's done a lot more than that but
he follows a ketogenic diet himself and
I asked what he had for breakfast and he
said well i usually have let's say
handful of macadamia nuts some eggs and
a tin of sardines and a half a tin of
canned oysters and I'd never even I
didn't even know there were such a thing
as canned oysters so I started emulating
his breakfast and I fell in love with
these sardines these wild planet
sardines how them yeah they're good
there's really well they're great but no
packed it all so when I'm traveling I'll
just throw a few of those tins in my
checked luggage and if I find myself in
a tight spot where I can't get a
breakfast it's acceptable to me then
I'll have that have you have you done
any experimentation with fasting five
years ago I fasted for four days I don't
know if you count that as
experimentation it was a different sort
of political reasons than it was it was
an interesting experience but it wasn't
really i don't think was the kind of
experience that
that you're asking me about right yes no
I fly I mean this is your podcast so I
do I want to do what you want to do but
i wouldn't mind continuing this
conversation because it's interesting
stuff to me yeah we can talk about the
fasting so there's I think it's seyfried
might be the last name it have to look
it up but they're they're number of
published researchers who believe that
as one tool in the toolkit not a
standalone monotherapy at all that
fasting can among other things let's
just say using the standard of care
chemotherapy or something like that
sensitized cancer cells to the effects
of those treatments while also
increasing the resilience of normal
cells so I have a friend who is at stage
three cancer and won't get into
specifics because his private guy but he
fasted for three continuous days prior
to his treatments and while the rest of
his cohort these other people were laid
out in bed for a day he was running 10
miles the next morning and that could
have been placebo who knows but there's
enough data to support that it that in
addition to that even using fasting
prophylactically you could potentially
and over the age of say forty everyone
has or most people will have I should
say precancerous cells in their bodies
and that in and of itself is not a
problem if they don't grow out of
control but fasting extended fasting
let's just say that and I think Dominic
generally does say five day or five to
seven day fast a few times a year can
help to purge those cells that might at
a later time metastasize or become a
problem so for for both sort of
philosophical and aesthetic reasons but
also physiological reasons I've started
scheduling regular fasts for myself but
what is the fat main under the
circumstance so what a fast means under
these circumstances is fast is and I've
changed over time i did i did a
distilled water fast which actually do
not recommend
I do not believe juice fasts are in fit
in this paradigm because you will never
click over into a katonic state if
you're feeding yourself glucose or in
this case fructose and for me I'll tell
you exactly what it looks like it looks
like waking up I will have tea or coffee
so a non-caloric beverage I will allow
myself some fat that could come in the
form of coconut oil or pure mct oil and
I am avoiding protein and carbohydrate
for the most part there are a few
allowances that I made in the last
go-round but generally speaking of
having water tea or coffee and allowing
a small amount of fat each day
particularly in the first few days and
when I say I made some allowances last
time around when i did my water fast i
lost i want to say about 12 pounds of
muscle it was a very very large amount
of muscle I've because it took me a long
time to go from glucose-dependent to fat
adapted and when your glucose-dependent
you run out of glycogen you start
breaking down muscle tissue in a process
called gluconeogenesis and the liver so
the second time around I did a 10-day
fast now where this is maybe the third
time and I got into ketosis very quickly
in about 18 hours and I'm measuring this
with a finger prick using a device
called the the precision extra x-tra
from from abbott labs looks like a
glucometer it is a glucometer and once i
get to about really over 0.5 millimolar
switch is the concentration of ketones
in the blood most people would say
that's ketosis I only feel it when i get
to about 1.2 1.3 but the point being I
got into ketosis very quickly some
already sparing muscle tissue and I was
doing DEXA scans these body composition
scans every two days or three days to
keep track of muscle mass and just
general composition I started losing
muscle I started losing muscle which I
did not want to have happened and I
spoke to Dominic this scientist I
mentioned and he said well you could try
using very very small amounts of
branched-chain amino acids very small
though so we're talking 1.5 grams in the
morning and then on a workout
if you're going to work out taking
perhaps to 23 grams intro workout and I
started doing that and I lost zero
muscle tissue over a nine and a half day
fast and the only protein I was
consuming where these let's just call it
one and a half to three and a half grams
of branched-chain amino acids per day
and I would very occasionally give
myself a treat of nori sheets in olive
oil source soaked in olive oil because
it's 10 calories there's nothing to it
really it's all if I it's all fat and at
this point as a working hypothesis I've
just assumed on some level that if
you're avoiding primarily protein and
carbohydrates the the fat a very very
very very ultra low-calorie ketogenic
diet that I then call a fast probably
provokes a lot of the the autophagy and
sell cleaning and so on that I'm looking
for in a fast without being just
distilled water where you get into
trouble with distilled water is you're
going to be peeling off electrolytes and
losing a lot of water and people end up
and this was this was consistent when i
did this my first seven day fast at a
medical clinic almost everyone had
tachycardia so rapid heart rate at night
they couldn't they couldn't sleep at all
and when you start to supplement with it
let's say bullion cubes in water or
magnesium potassium etc then you're
totally fine and you can sleep and I
think that's cholinergic response but
there you have it so that's uh that's
that's a big part of my monthly and
record really scheduling now though is
the fasting hmm have you written about
it at all I have actually and I mean
we're certainly here to talk about what
you're up to but that my my brave I'm
just cured on have to just yep we don't
know no no no no no I don't mind I mean
I've had enough caffeine to enjoy
talking but but the the the my I mean
have a brand new book that's coming out
in a few days called tools of titans and
one of the longest chapters is on
everything I've learned
including my personal routine related to
fasting and and keep the ketogenic diet
but it's it's very neglected I think
people think about fixing problems by
adding things this is a very natural
instinct and it's it's not as common to
think about subtracting things and then
reintroducing them in and this is
perhaps an extreme example but fasting
you just removing all the inputs and
allowing nature to try to do its work
and you see some really odd things
happen a lot of people with joint
injuries resolve that have them resolve
themselves I can't explain exactly why
that's the case but I've seen it in
dozens of cases it's really odd let me
ask you we talked about writing you
brought up bird by bird which completely
saved me when I was writing my second
book and I've given it to a lot of
friends since I'd love to talk about
your writing process a little bit how
many books at this point have you
authored or co-authored 20 god it's a
lot of books yeah it's a lot of books as
the answer that is the answers yeah and
you you very often seem to write books
that are similar to some of mine in the
sense that you could you could bludgeon
a mugger to death with with some of
these books I mean there's not small
books in all cases what does your when
you are on deadline let's just say
you're a month out from book deadline
what does your daily routine look like
you know if it's really different from
cookbooks are different from other
things or they may be similar to what
you do but with cookbooks the process
especially the big ones and there are
now five including the how to bake
everything the latest there are five had
a cooked everything book six if you
count that one is the second edition of
another so I'm how to cook everything
than a second edition of how to cook
everything and had a great vegetarian
how to cook everything the basics
haddock everything fast and now how to
bake everything those are all so big
that they're really years-long projects
and a month out from deadline doesn't
mean anything because I tend to submit
things and quarters or halves or
whatever and I'm working on editing the
first half wall still finishing the
second half and so on I think on a on a
book project like food matters or or
vegan before six where there is much
more writing when it was more of a long
essay or novella length si I think in
the last few weeks a lot of what's going
on is tweaking tweaking language and
trying to make sure that sometimes you
read things so many times that you don't
realize what's wrong and you need a big
chunk of time to get away from it and
come back and say oh this whole chapter
and half the paragraph should be
somewhere else like it's just not
tracking right and those are only things
that you can catch after you've written
something and let it right or at least
for me after you've written something
let it rest for a while so I think more
interesting that what happens in the
last month might maybe what happens in
the last six months and I hope that part
of that last six months is setting
things aside so that I can come back and
look at them fresh mm-hmm and when
you're in the sick of writing when you
are actually in production mode and not
stepping away what does what does the
structure of your day look like well I'm
I'm about to I'm hoping in January maybe
I'm hoping in March that I should stall
a little bit but I'm about to enter one
of
periods and I you know I'm the plan is
to get up at 4-430 and work from work
seriously from five till ten and then
let the rest of my day take whatever
shape it takes but I need that if I'm
working you know add my most serious
level it has to be in absolute peace and
quiet with nothing around and you know
no email no phone calls no none of that
stuff and the only time I have the
discipline to do that is when i first
get up in the morning I read about
writers to work late into the night and
um man that is so not me oh not and when
you wake up what's what happens besides
brushing the teeth and so on what is the
what is leading up to sitting down to
write and then what is the first 30
minutes look like um first 30 minutes of
coffee uh and then there's sort of a
bunch of like knuckle cracking throat
clearing I might do some email or it
might look at the paper something like I
just really it's almost warming up my
fingers at the keyboard and then often
it's rewriting something that I've done
the day before or if there's something
hot in my head it's just spilling it out
and I'm a firm believer in mrs. there's
no secrets in bird by bird most writers
say the same thing this idea that you
have to give you have to get a lousy
dressed down before you can do anything
good and that you just need to spill the
contents of your brain out on what will
call the paper you know out onto the
screen and and then worry about making
it beautiful later I understand there
are some writers who really write a
careful sentence at a time but most
writers who talked to feel like there
are two different kinds of processes
once one is kind of a brain dump and one
is this refine refine refine and you sit
in front of the computer and clock your
five hours and
matter what or is there have you left
yourself a starting point it's the
hemingway-esque style of stopping kind
of mid paragraph so you know where to
start the next day I know I've ever done
I've never done that then you know i'm
not going to compare myself to hemming
will miss it was a different kind of
writing anyway but I think that I you
know I don't do outlines very well but
sometimes I'll get to a point in writing
something where I'll say okay here i can
see the rest of this chapter or even the
rest of the next few chapters and i'll
just make some notes first this then you
do this then go do this then do that and
that's as far as close to an outline as
I get and I'm uh I like what that
happens but if it doesn't happen it just
flows I've yeah I've never had what
people call writers block I've had
months where I didn't do a lot of
writing but it never really had to or
wanted to write something and not been
able to do it so um it's usually you
know I don't recall an experience where
I'd gotten up in that what I've been in
that kind of rhythm and it's funny it
goes back to running in a way it's just
when you run every day you just run
every day and you don't think about it
that much you get up and maybe do
something maybe you don't but at some
point early in the day you tie the shoes
on and you go out and it's kind of the
same thing there might be months where
I'm not really writing anything serious
but if I am writing something serious
it's just mostly getting up and doing it
she mentioned not really having writer's
block or not thinking of it much
certainly but let's let's talk about
failures or mistakes for a second so how
has how is it failure or an apparent
failure in your life set you up for
later success if you can think of any or
do you have a favorite failure of yours
that actually ended up being really
important to your career or life um
there was a there was a period where
really by my standards I was a failure
and that was because I had done a bunch
of writing when I was in my early 20s
and then but not really been paid much
for it but then when I started to want
to write when I decided I was going to
write for a living no one was interested
in anything that I was writing and this
went on for two or three years I was
back in the mid to late 70s so you know
he's a while ago but in those days the
advice was you do well I've tried to
write fiction but I didn't think was
very good so then I was trying to write
freelance articles and in those days
with wisdom was you wrote letters to
editors and you and you said here's the
story i want to write and then they
would politely say no thanks or they
would ignore you entirely and that went
on for a long time during which i made a
living by being a traveling salesman
i've sold photographic equipment so that
and that went on for a while and I um I
kept trying and trying and trying and
failing Enzo and I guess that's failing
i mean not succeeding anyway and then uh
the funny thing is was that people
thought i was a good traveling salesman
but i knew that i was a terrible
traveling salesman because i knew that
my heart wasn't in it and i wasn't i
didn't particularly believe in what i
was selling i wasn't that interested in
it i was selling photographic equipment
i might have said that I ready for
me but I was driving around from store
to store saying you want to buy these
tripods you want to buy these notebooks
you want a buzz and I didn't really care
whether people bought him or not because
the marginal income was not all that
significant so um but that is to say I
was making enough money from the job
that any additional sale I made a little
more money but it didn't seem like it
was worth killing myself for it but as I
said I didn't really believe in the
product so there was there was that and
then I finally solved my first piece
that my first piece was a food piece and
do you remember what it was about the
yet oh they have it on my wall um I I
was in a karate class that's been a
karate class with a guy named Chris
Angermann and I'm Chris was in New Haven
and Chris was writing theater reviews
for the local weekly but that's not what
he did for living and I said how did
that happen and he said I'll just go
talk to George de stefano he's the arts
editor down there and fill it to do
something so I went in the next day and
I talked to Georgia Stefano and I said
you know I could review restaurants
better than the people you have
reviewing restaurants now and he said
well right one and and we'll see what
happens and I wrote one i slaved over it
for 24 hours and I brought it in and uh
he really liked it and I you know it's
interesting the date on it is march
first nineteen eighty so it's now what
is that 30 going on thirty seven years
ago he really liked it and I i have it
on my wall and I I think it's really
good quite happy about it so that was my
first success and I and and the
interesting thing after that was that I
became a very aggressive salesman of my
own stuff hmm I think you can probably
relate to that and I think a lot of you
know entrepreneurial writers can relate
to that which is we have to go out there
and say you want to buy this book you
want to buy this article title it up
because I'm going to say it and the way
others haven't and it's an interesting
topic and i'll do a good job blah blah
and you know I've done I've made my
living doing that for since then and
I've had setbacks and I you know some
years are better than others and so on
but I do believe that I'm a good writer
and and obviously I've learned a lot
over the years and I've learned
tremendous amount about food which is
why if we go back to that first question
about what I don't talk about that I do
there is this kind of not it's not a
secret life but I do cook all the time
and I'm always amazed at how both of how
much there is to learn and how much I
actually have Pat learned how much I
know and modesty aside how much I know
so I do think there is this way in which
that period of seeing that I didn't
believe in what I was doing set me up
for being excited and being assertive if
not aggressive about once I started
doing things that I did believe in what
I was doing you mentioned that you
people considered you a good salesman of
this photographic equipment were did any
of that get translated over to selling
your own work and I'm just wondering
what specifically makes you or one good
at selling either of those things like
what was it that made you better at
selling your ideas or the photographic
equipment than some of the other people
who were doing the same I think they
thought I was good at selling
photographic equipment because I was a
nice guy and people liked me I knew how
to talk and actually I am curious about
other people's lives so I'm really I
mean it happened here this is supposed
to be an interview of me we end up
talking about something you're doing for
you know for 10 minutes and i think
that's not that's not a contrivance i
I'm not that interested in myself I know
what's going on in my self so I like to
hear other people's stories and I think
I've always liked that and that's being
a reporter and that's being a journalist
and yeah I think I've always had that
that curiosity and and that's
I think if you show a genuine interest
in other people which I do because I am
genuinely interested in other people
they like you do you have any quotes
that you live your life buyers think of
Austin I bet I do but I can't think of
him right now that's not like I have any
it's not like they're mantras that's for
sure yeah but I'm sure that there are
things that you know I actually you know
I said I said to my kids but it's not
maybe I still feel this way because i am
this writing project that i'm about to
take on as a complete and total stretch
for me and i know we'll probably talk
about this but i just started doing a
podcast and that's a stretch for me so i
do think that um one thing that I
learned and it's interesting because it
goes back door is just talking about but
one thing that I have learned is that if
you are afraid to fail then you're not
going to succeed because they're you
know there is no success without failure
and fear of failure keeps people from
trying and then there's no possible
success so that's that's not exactly a
mantra it's something that I know I note
through and I've and I've said it to my
kids and to other people and I lived my
life lived my life that way it makes me
think of a video that actually had a
huge impact of me when I was about 15
years old it was video of a very very
legendary wrestling coach named Dan
Gable in Iowa and he was doing a
post-game analysis on one of the Iowa
Hawkeyes I think was a dual meet
competition and he was yelling at one of
the athletes who got a tie and he said
you you just didn't want to lose you
didn't want to lose because he beat you
twice before and so you got a tie you
never win that way the idea of being
like wanting wanting not to fail and
wanting to win or two very different
things and
um what would advise and this is a
cliched question but sometimes it goes
somewhere what advice would you give or
do you wish you'd received when you or
say 20 25 or 30 you can pick you can
pitch pick whichever or any time that
you needed some advice for that matter
well you know it is you said it was a
cliche and it's so so often repeated and
it is so corny and but this is my and my
parents never said this to me but i
think they telegraphed it to me despite
themselves and despite the way they live
their own lives and you know that's not
we're probably not going to get into
that but but um uh my parents were funny
and that their their verbal cues I don't
know where to go with this okay so I do
think that there are ways in which my
parents taught me things that were very
unintentional on their part very little
through with how they live their own
lives and even what they believed and
yet somehow there were messages that I
managed to absorb that maybe they didn't
absorb them from my parents at all maybe
absorb them from elsewhere but it anyway
I you know it's the follow your passion
thing I think you have to do what it is
you think you want to do because you're
not going to succeed at stuff that you
don't want to do so I wasn't I was
passionate about food in the cooking
sense it wasn't that I ever thought oh
I'm going to write about food it was
that I thought I'm gonna write and i
really like cooking and those two things
together really worked for me and I
didn't sit around saying oh I'm
passionate about this is what I must do
those are just the things that I felt
that I wanted to do and I don't know I
could've think other things could have
worked out in my life in much different
ways of course and they might have
worked that better they might have
worked at worse but these were things
but I was but I wanted to do and wanted
to
last part of my life I think that's
that's the advice I say to people or
time they say what should i do it's
really like what what is you want to do
because that's that's what you got to
know what I don't know if you had any
external input or pressure or advice
given to you but if you hadn't listened
to that if you would listen to other
people what do you think you would have
ended up doing or where would you be my
parents would have loved it if I was a
doctor so the thing is that i am when i
was young i felt like there were so many
options of things to do that it was
impossible to decide which one was going
to be the right path so to decide in
high school which is sort of what it
would have taken or early in college to
become a doctor it just seemed way too
early but to say i'm going to be a
writer was so vague and meaning what it
is less every door open and it was only
later that I realized every time you say
yes to something you said no too many
many other things not every other thing
but any time you make a commitment
you're making commitment in a direction
and it seals off other directions at
least for that for that moment and
[Music]
that's an important lesson also is that
it's not only the things that you say no
to that shut down certain avenues it's
what you say yes to because when if you
say yes to something that you're not
going to enter into wholeheartedly
you're still going to take time which is
you know what I guess we could say the
most precious thing we have and devoted
to that that path which means you're not
giving time to another path so now if
you and Anakin these can be daily
decisions or these can be life decisions
if you're watching TV you're not
exercising if you're cooking you're not
sleeping I mean whatever it is you say
yes to some things that you're saying no
to something else and then in the long
run if you're if you are 17 years old
and you say i'm going to be a doctor
you've just
if you stay on that path you shut off
all these other careers I mean our
remarkable people have more than one
career but that's not the norm yeah I
want to say this is a Steve Jobs quote
but it makes me think of the innovation
is saying no to a thousand things but
it's like as you pointed out it's also
saying yes to exist is echoing the
friend of mine who's been on the podcast
named derek sivers is an entrepreneur
but the saying yes only to the hell yes
one hundred percent in options and not
to thee that could be kind of cool
options because those you will you will
drown yourself in these mediocre
commitments and as you as you put it it
displaces the opportunity to do these
things that you actually care about what
did hold you now mark I'm going to be 67
in February so if we had here let's say
you're 80 year old self just poof
appeared on the couch what I not that
far away not that far away so what would
your 80 year old what advice do you
think you're 80 year old self would give
your current self that's great um well I
guess I could say the kind of advice
that I'd like be eight my 80 year old
self to give my current self yeah yeah I
would think I would hope that it would
be don't age too fast or don't write
things off too quickly keep changing
keep struggling to do newer better more
exciting things and don't be afraid to
jump off metaphorical cliffs mm-hmm and
then that is you know what I'd really
hate it if my 80 year old self was
saying to me now you should be much more
conservative in the way your legs shake
far fewer chances you know that God I
don't want that hmm and you said don't
write things off too quickly could you
elaborate on that or give us an example
there there are projects there are
things that seem too hard at first and
then they
turn out to be you know the [ __ ] the fun
thing for me I don't and I don't know
how many people feel this way but often
the fun thing for me is this deep end of
the learning curve um so whether we're
talking about the fasting stuff that you
were describing before which is
completely new and wild to me and makes
me feel like oh I'd like to explore that
are we talking about backpacking which
is something I've taken up recently and
um just completely surprised me how much
I've liked it or pilates for that matter
same thing or backgammon I mean all
these things that um you know i never
thought i'd be interested in it for one
reason other i became interested in that
and i love that stuff i love starting
new things and i love the part of it
that's that that goes from god i'm
completely clueless at this too well
i've gained some confidence in this
arena and isn't that nice and that's
like that to me is the most fun gaining
confidence i think is some one of the
most fun things in life and um something
that I hope I can continue to do when
it's funny because you know I gained
confidence in cooking for example a long
time ago but I like getting better and
better at it but some things come and
some things go and what they've had in
common is that I love that I love that
steep end of the learning curve so why
start a podcast and what is the what is
the name of the podcast the podcast is
called get bit for better or worse it's
a name we kind of like we'll see if
other people like it it goes it goes
back in a way to to why I left the times
i left the times because I felt I'd left
the plans for a variety of reasons but
one of them was that I felt constrained
and I felt like I couldn't say anything
I want to say about any subject I wanted
to tackle and I thought whether it two
ways of dealing with this wanted to do a
newsletter which I might still do and
the
is these guys I quite liked came to me
and said would like do a podcast and
it's funny I hadn't listened to many
podcasts I mean I've listened to cereal
like everybody else in the United States
but I hadn't listened to really any sort
of personal people telling their stories
and I started to do that and I thought
this is great these people are able to
do whatever they want and it's not no
one says it has to be 30 minutes and no
one says it has to be two hours and no
one says you can't talk to this guy and
no one says you can't do this thing and
it's self publishing in a way and it's
verbal instead of written and I thought
that's a that's appealing to because I
you know I do like to talk and I like I
like interviews a lot I mean I like both
ends of interviews and and I'm I'm
pretty good at interviewing people and
so we thought we'd give it a shot and
think three or six months went by and we
were you know doing samples of this and
we were thinking of who might sponsor
and how we might organize or whatever
and then at some point I said we should
just do a show you know it's not going
to cost us that much money or that much
time to to put something together why
don't we do a show so among people got
together where I'm living which is about
Sand River about 50 miles from New York
and it's a bit too it's a working farm
and I'm is a bigger story than that but
that battle do and my daughter Kate came
up with her new boy at that point
newborn son and and through of the
producers came and has it happened the
guy who was doing a story about me for
epicurious came a couple other people
showed up and for two days we we made
phone calls and did a did a couple of
interviews and we did some walking and
golf carting around the farm a little
bit and talked about this and that and
we did a bunch of cooking and talked
about that and it was really really fun
um
so then they went back fashion mark or
through the people I'm working with went
back and edited the hell out of all this
you know by that time we probably have
six hours of material edited it down to
30 or 40 minutes and we we just sort of
self-published it last week if you can
find it on my website on the get bit
website and in the twittersphere
whatever but we were really happy about
how it came out and I loved I loved the
process it was like we just did stuff
for two days and Josh mostly was walking
around with microphones while we were
doing it and I yeah I think it worked
out well so we're gonna we're pushing
ahead we're gonna go heavy is it get bit
with with 2 t's be itt or bi t ah don't
be i TP okay epi just making sure my
name right right the podcasting yeah I I
found podcasting so fun as an
experimental medium because as you said
there are no rules really and it just
provides you an opportunity also to
explore your thoughts in a way and the
thoughts of others that can translate to
at least for me writing much more
clearly later I'm walking through and
developing my thoughts as I'm listening
to people and asking questions now you
have interviewed a lot of people what
what are what are some undervalued
questions some questions over notice
whether they're follow ups or just
openers whatever it might be what are
some what are some questions that you
have found very very helpful or valuable
I don't think I don't think my answers
gonna make you happy I'm not very happy
in general it's okay hoping you could
give you what you want hi this is me I
mean I don't pretend to teach
interviewing and and actually tried to
teach journalism last year and I felt
like I wasn't very good at that either
you know I think after this hour-long
conversation it's clear that i'm not
modest when I when I don't need to be
but when I
cognize something that I'm not good at
UM I'm had people talk about that also
and I don't be i'm good about teaching
some of the things that i think i do
well but i think that um you know what
maybe we'll like this answer because i'm
thinking about what just happened in the
course of the last hour I don't believe
in having Pat questions for interviews I
am I might have a couple key things that
I want the person I'm interviewing to
cover but I actually think the best
interviews our conversations and that
you have to see what the natural
conversation is and that you're any
subject of any interview can give a
variety of different interviews the
interviewer has to determine what he or
she if I'm interviewing somebody I have
to figure out what they are doing that's
interesting to me and hope that that is
interesting to other people also so I
mean you can think of anyone you want
but it's most likely that the questions
that they most often get are not the
most interesting questions and they're
also not the questions that are going to
make them think because if you say to me
how did you start cooking it's a
question that I you know that I've
answered I mean literally two hundred
times so I can't come up with it
anything I say is going to sound
rehearsed whereas if we have a
conversation as we're doing which is why
I realized you are going to Santa if we
have a conversation then I'm taken by
surprise but what by whatever comes next
and I'm forced to actually think and I
think that as an interviewer that's what
you want to do is get the person you're
talking to to actually think I am I just
thought of maybe a coping strategy for
when you get asked that question again
and I I heard that Nick Nolte this is
rumor but it's been verified a few times
that he got so sick of answering the
same questions that he would just make
up
extremely elaborate lies and he would
tell no I went through that I've done
never get in there done that um it's so
it's it's satisfying good kind of fun
but it doesn't I mean and it also forces
you to be creative in a way that you
might not otherwise be but um and want
to sit around lying what sighs I don't
know nothing that I feel like really
yeah certainly it's a headache for the
publicist who gets the fact-checking
call at the end of the day but let's
let's talk about another topic that I I
don't think you are aware is actually
something that is near and dear to my
heart which is baking and baking was in
fact the first type of cooking I ever
tempted because I was trying in 1999 to
follow a ketogenic diet and the the
tools and packaged foods and so on that
support people are trying to follow an
Atkins like diet now did not exist them
and you get so sick of eggs meat water
eggs meat water you just want to have
something crunchy and the only thing
available at the time was pork rinds and
i said no i'm sick of pork rinds I need
something crunchy so I went out and
tried to find soy protein powders that
might be suitable for baking I want to
make cookies and I'd never made cookies
so I got really into baking and uh I
found it suited my personality which
made sense later when I was talking to
somebody at the the CIA not the Central
Intelligence Agency with Culinary
Institute on right and I asked how they
steered people towards savory or sweet
and they said well sometimes we'll just
ask them do you like folding your
underwear and socks and if the answer is
yes then we point them towards the
baking and I was like and I was like
okay well I don't do that but I do have
a lot of monkish like tendencies so end
baking was really fast i enjoyed the
immediate feedback what what to you
makes bay
King fascinating or fun like what what
what are most people missing who haven't
ever attempted to make something here's
the thing i don't think that baking is
all that different from cooking and i
think the answer to that question goes
for cooking as well as baking and the
answer is you wind up with a finished
product that makes you happy in a
variety of ways plus you can eat it so
if taking is your passion i think maybe
you're more interested in the final
product having a very specific shape and
form that's pleasing to the eye now
because cooking is been a little Messier
you know a stew does not have the same
the same aesthetic qualities as a cake
or or even or cookie if it's sort of
more freeform and flowing I me on the
other hand there's nothing more
beautiful than an omelet so cooking can
be of course as beautiful as baking but
I think that both have that thing in
common you start a project in a
reasonably short period of time you
finish it it has a lot of wonderful
aesthetic qualities and you get to eat
it and you get to nurture people UK you
know often you get to nurture people you
care about which is quite an incredible
thing so how many pages is how to make
everything mmm 700 something 700 alright
so how to make everything everything's
all inclusive but not everything of
course everything I know how to bake
which is a lot so which is like I don't
want to hell I always feel like this
title which has a story of its own as
you know was a bit a bit tongue-in-cheek
at the beginning but um I always feel
like I have to apologize for it even
though obviously not meant to be taken
literally but yeah well i mean you're
talking to the guy who wrote something
called the 4-hour workweek which you did
you detect you'd expect to find after
the rotisserie chicken before the spray
on hair at three in the morning on TV so
you
yes I I know the feeling in that book
though so seven in our pages if you
wanted to get somebody hooked on baking
and simultaneously give them a a dish
that would teach them principles that
apply to a lot of other dishes or just
great principles for cooking is there is
there any particular recipe that comes
to mind well um it might be a cheap but
I would say something like pizza because
um it's got cooking and baking in it so
it's it's more than you know you're
making a sauce which i think is an
incredibly valuable thing and you're
learning how to make a dough that it
incorporates yeast which is something
that can really serve you well but uh
you know I always say when people say
how should I start I say just pick up a
cookbook and find something that really
appeals to you find something that you
want to make and then take your time and
tackle that yeah that is what I think I
think that that the best dish for a
person to cook first is the dish that
appeal to that person most and that's
sort of the way I best know to guarantee
or at least to nearly guarantee success
mm-hmm well I think pizza probably hits
eighty percent of the population is
check that box alike because of that
good yeah and and I remember I picked up
is it Marcel are more chela huzzah
Nigella March Ella and and hurt her what
is her to defer her magnum opus I'm
blanking on the name here but all the
first thing that she did was was uh me
too classics of classes classics of
Italian cook that's right and and I
remember being intimidated but focusing
on the roast chicken and to this day I
think that that is my go-to approach to
roasting chickens and it was just it was
the least intimidating or one
less intimidating that I could approach
and what do you know that people always
used to say that you can judge it you
can judge a restaurant best on its roast
chicken because it's the hardest thing
to make that I don't think that's
actually true but many people think that
you know making a great roast chicken is
actually and it's true making a great
race chicken is not easy making a decent
roast chickens pretty easy making a
great one it's not easy I've heard this
say I've heard the same thing about
making a French omelet that people will
say okay let's see how you make a French
omelet and that was also one of the
litmus tests I or one of the I'm sure
many different tests that people could
throw out there i am not a chef enjoy
cooking but certainly wouldn't put
myself on the line anywhere even half
respectable uh-huh so I mark where
Canada practice as you know it's like
everything else it's all practice and
the more as you pointed out the more you
enjoy the weather it's the skill or the
dish that you pick out the more
incentivized and motivated you're going
to be to practice in the first place
mark where can I guess I guess two
things so the first is we'll wrap up
here and i'll let you get running so i
know we have a heart out so the first is
where can people find out more about you
and find you on the internet etc and
then last is if you have any parting ask
of my audience or recommendation could
be anything what would that be well
those are great questions thank you for
asking them i mean you know i have it
alive and well website called mark
bittman calm so that's where you can
find me most easily and I'd love people
to listen to get bit and and tell us
either on the get bedside or through
twitter which i'm at bittman what they
think of it yeah and of course I'd love
people to check out how to bake
everything but that goes with that same
and now that I hope that after this
conversation people are curious about it
and will
check it out it's obviously a great
season for it and it's like everything
else I've done the most accessible
possible book I could do so yeah those
are those are my two requests payment
and it's it's sitting right in my
kitchen next to a bunch of others that
are my favorites like seven fires and
some of some of my some of my go-to so
how to make everything as as a spot in
prime real estate right on my my kitchen
shelf uh and mark I am sure you'll be
doing a lot of cooking coming up on the
holidays so I wish you and yours a very
happy holidays thank you for making the
time great chatting with you can really
a lot of fun i hope we get to do it
again and i will be working on my pizza
for cheat day and exo-m everybody
listening as always you can find the
show notes links to everything we talked
about at four hour work week calm
forward slash podcast and until next
time and as always thank you for
listening hey guys this is Tim again
just a few more things before you take
off number one this is five bullet
Friday do you want to get a short email
from me would you enjoy getting a short
email for me every Friday event provides
a little morsel of fun before the
weekend and five bullet Friday is a very
short email where I share the coolest
things I've found or that I've been
pondering over the week that could
include favorite new albums that I've
discovered it could include gizmos and
gadgets and all sorts of weird [ __ ] that
I've somehow dug up in the the world of
the esoteric as I do it could include
favorite articles that i have read and
that I've shared with my close friends
for instance and it's very short it's
just a little tiny bite of goodness
before you head off for the weekend so
if you want to receive that check it out
just go to four hour work week dot com
that's four hour work week com all
spelled out and just drop in your email
and you will get the very next one and
if you sign up I hope you enjoyed this
episode is brought to you by wealthfront
and this is a very unique sponsor
wealthfront is a massively
disruptive in a good way set it and
forget it investing service led by
technologists for places like Apple and
world-famous investors it has exploded
in popularity in the last two years and
they now have more than two and a half
billion dollars under management in fact
some of my very good friends investors
in Silicon Valley have millions of their
own money in wealth front so the
question is why why is it so popular why
is it unique because you can get
services previously reserved for the
ultra wealthy but only pay pennies on
the dollar for them and this is because
they use smarter software instead of
retail locations bloated sales teams etc
and I'll come back to that in a second I
suggest you check out wealthfront calm
forward slash Tim take the risk
assessment quiz which only takes two to
five minutes and they'll show you for
free exactly the portfolio they put you
in and if you just want to take their
advice run with it do it yourself you
can do that or as I would you can set it
and forget it here's why the value of
wealth front is in the automation of
habits and strategies that investors
should be using on a regular basis but
normally aren't great investing is a
marathon not a sprint and little things
that you may or may not be familiar with
like automatic tax loss harvesting
rebalancing your portfolio across more
than ten asset classes and dividend
reinvestment add up to very large
amounts of money over longer periods of
time wealthfront as I mentioned since
it's using software instead of retail
locations etc can offer all of this at
low costs that were previously
completely impossible right off the bat
you never pay commissions or account
fees for everything they charge Oh point
two five percent per year on assets
above the first fifteen thousand which
is managed for free if you use my link
wealthfront calm forward slash Tim that
is less than five dollars a month to
invest a thirty thousand dollar account
for instance now normally when I have a
sponsor around this show is because I
use them and recommend them in this case
it's a little different I don't use
wealthfront yet because I'm not allowed
to here's the deal they wanted to
sponsor this podcast but because of SEC
regulations companies that invest your
money are not allowed to use client
testimonials so I couldn't be a user and
have them on the podcast but I've been
so impressed by wealthfront that I've
invested a significant amount of my own
money at least for me in the team and
the company itself so I am an investor
and hope to soon use it as a client now
back to the recommendation as a Tim
Ferriss show listener you'll get $15,000
managed for free if you decide to open
an account but just start with seeing
the portfolio that they would suggest
for you take two minutes fill out their
questionnaire at wealthfront com forward
slash Tim it's fast it's free there's no
downside that I can think of this
episode is brought to you by Vimeo Pro
which is the ideal video hosting
platform for entrepreneurs and in fact a
bunch of my startups already use vimeo
pro including wealthfront who uses it to
explain how wealthfront works TaskRabbit
uses it to tell their company's story
and there are many other names you would
recognize among their customers Airbnb
etsy etc why do they use it well Vimeo
Pro provides enterprise level video
hosting for a fraction of the usual cost
features include gorgeous high-quality
playback with no ads up to 20 gigabytes
of video storage every week unlimited
plays and views and a fully customizable
video player which can include your logo
custom outro etc you also get VIP
support and you get all of this for just
199 per year that's seventeen dollars a
month with no complicated bandwidth
calculations or hidden fees and you can
try it risk-free for 30 days so check it
out vimeo com forward slash business
that's VI m EO calm forward slash
business and use promo code Tim to get
twenty five percent off that's a special
discount just for you guys so check it
out vimeo com forward slash business
promo code tip
you